hi my name is Amir Azadi I'm in machine
learning team wolfram research and I
will be talking about unsupervised
learning function in Wolfram language
hello everyone I'm Amira's Eddie and
today I'll be talking about unsupervised
learning functions and some new updates
that will be coming in 12.1 and some
review of new features that we had in 12
what is unsupervised learning
broadly speaking unsupervised learning
tries to learn unknown patterns from
unlabeled data which can unlock various
tasks it is in contrast to classify and
predict where you have labeled data so
unsupervised learning tasks that I will
be talking about today I will sort from
clustering then go on to dimension
reduction and then the next step would
be learn distribution which will unlock
a lot of other tasks that will follow
like find anomalies and synthesize
missing values so this is sort with just
clustering one of the classic examples
of unsupervised learning and the goal is
simply partitioning data into clusters
of similar elements and the measure is
based on some distances or these
similarity functions two main functions
that we'll be using today is find
clusters that you can input the data
directly and get the clustering result
as an output as a default output and the
other one is cluster classified so these
functions works on a variety of data
types including images numerical and
nominal dates and times so let's look at
first the first one find clusters of
let's try it on a list of numerical
values so you can see that it returns a
sub list of clusters you can also has a
second argument
i specify how many cluster you want and
it will tell you that there are two
clusters of similar elements the other
function is a cluster classifier which
returns a classifier function cluster
classifier function you can train it on
a set of data and then you can use it
for your test data which returns the
index of the clusters associated with
each of your examples as I told you it
works on a variety of data like images
let's look at like train classifier
cluster classifier on images asking for
three clusters and you can gather those
by their cluster index the main thing
that we can have is the clustering
methods you can specify what method to
use there around the ten methods that
has been implemented and a few of them
will be updated in 12.1 and different
clustering methods often lead to
different partitioning of your data and
the methods performance in general
depends on various things like the
shapes of the clusters the sizes density
and level of noise in your data and in
general there is no good universal
metric to compare the performances of
different clustering methods for
instance looking at this complex complex
structure we as humans who would like to
find patterns in everything yes we might
find different patterns but different
clustering methods might result in
different clusters all the methods in
12-point ones are documented in details
about the details of the algorithms and
users can go and look at different
methods and choose the one that they
think that it's best possible for their
data but let's look at one of the
applications and one of the new updates
on one of the widely used clustering
methods DBS scan which finds costs of
this method finds cluster has a
connected component of highly dense
regions you can go and look at the
details of it in the documentation pages
and which accompanied with some toy
datasets and the performance of that but
one important thing is that the DVS can
can also find outliers and the outliers
would be labeled as the missing
anomalies labeled as any changes drop
them if you want with a sub option of
the metal drop animals values it will be
in 12.1 and you can also see that
clusters of anisotropy a Gaussian
structure you can also see the grey dots
or the outliers picked by a devious
convertor so let's change gear and go to
the other task of the unsupervised
learning dimensional reduction which is
often used for visualizing higher
dimensional data in lower dimensional
space and it is good for future
discovery and so on again two main
functions that we will be using today is
dimensional reduction and dimension
reduce which works for again variety of
data types like images textual and
numerical and nominal data again you can
here I have a simple three dimensional
vector dimension reduce directly give
you the reduced data in the target
dimension you can also specify the
dimension of the target to be for
example one the other function related
in this related to dimension and
dimensional reduction analysis dimension
reduction itself which you can give it a
set of training data and it will return
a dimension reducer function that then
you can use that function to reduce new
data and depending on the method that
you use you can have two types of map
from higher dimension to a lower
dimension it can be a linear mapping or
nonlinear mapping by default the
automatic methods would do a linear
mapping of your data a linear mapping
are all somehow different variations of
principal component analysis and lure
matrix factorization that tries to find
the targeted space spanned by direction
of maximum variance of the data so those
are your principal components that
linear methods or automatic method would
use so let's look at one of the example
using iris Fisher iris dataset which is
a data sets of different species of
flowers given its physical
characteristics like sample and petal
length so it's a four dimensional data
sets and we can just perform a
dimensional reduction on that and you
can see that plotting that in the
reduced dimension you kinda see that the
same species clustered together in this
lower dimensional space but this linear
mapping doesn't always work especially
if your data lives on a higher
dimensional manifold which is complex
and it's nonlinear a very simple toy
dataset that shows you these
nonlinearities is Swiss roll data sets
so as if you just use a linear method on
that it would just it would just squish
all of your data projected to just one
plane so you just lose all the
information about the global topology of
your manifold that that data lives in
there are a few methods in nonlinear
methods that you can use one of them is
like ll a locally linear embedding which
tries to cut
preserve the local neighborhood
relationships of the points and it kinda
as you can see can unroll the data in
lower dimensional space without using
the information about the local and also
the global geometry of your data you can
also draw examples of dimensional
reduction that you can use methods like
a variational auto encoder that you can
use that depends on the under the hood
it uses neural networks and so on and
you can use it it's very good using our
images and so on I won't go into the
details are not much time on that and
I'm gonna switch gear to the next
section which is learning the
distribution of the data the statistical
distribution of the data that underlies
data this data can be anything can be
just numerical variables could be
numerical vectors in any dimensions it
can be nominal mix of those images and
so on so what is it good to know the
distribution of the data so you can do a
lot of things and you can it's one of
the central applications of unsupervised
learning actually you can you can by
having well-trained distribution you can
generate a new sample you can synthesize
new samples you can query probabilities
of new samples you can find out lawyers
and anomalous examples you can fill in
missing values you can Dino is and D
corrupt your data so there's a variety
of tasks that can be unlocked by knowing
the distribution so the main function is
just learn distribution involve from
language introduced in 12 and there
would be a detailed talk by a TN burn or
that 3:30 today which will tell you all
about in details and all the knobs of
learn distribution but I would need to
go through quickly
how it works you just give the alarm
distribution your data and it would
return I'll learn the distribution based
on that you can ask for a PDF of a new
example you can also get random variate
work on the learned distribution and get
and synthesize new examples unlike the
other methods where the automatic
setting for method selection does not
exist since there is no universal metric
for clustering and for dimensional
reduction to compare the performances
here we have a for learn distribution we
have a very clear metric which is the
cross entropy the log probability of
your examples and you can simply compare
all the methods performances with just
this one metric and what under the hood
learn distribution does is it would go
try different methods and subsets of
data and it will pick the one that with
a smallest loss in general learning the
distribution from unlabeled data it's
more harder than classification tasks
and there will be some more methods in
the in the future and there are the
problems some methods wouldn't be able
to correctly find probability density
functions like Yan's that are very good
in synthesizing new images but you
cannot really get the probabilities so
let's look at one of the example again
on fisheries datasets and I only pick
two of the features in the data since
it's a four dimensional data are just
make it a two-dimensional based on pedal
and several lengths of the flowers and
you can learn distribution on that and
then you can get like random variate new
examples and you can look at the
hunters of probabilities overlay that on
top of it with the data points as you
can see places where you have a lot of
dates so you have two peaks of your
distribution as you go further away from
the peaks you would kind of have no mass
probability mass density for instant if
I asked for a PDF of Swat like somewhere
here a test example here you get a
pretty low PDF so now we can say aha it
might give you a hint that some examples
could be anomalies but let's talk more
about anomalous examples so in general a
naive definition of anomalies is
examples that are kind of different from
the others here we focus on the problem
and you have anomalies are rare if
they're not rare we can use just
classify and if you have labeled data
but it is only when you have unlabeled
data and anomalies are rare these are
the assumption and the other assumption
is that a distribution you have a known
distribution given the known
distribution you can find out of the
solution examples anomalies in another
world with a function called the rarer
probabilities which what it does is it
computes the total probability so it's
for the it computes the total
probability for distribution to generate
samples with PDF lower than the example
that you're querying for example if I
have a learned distribution here and I
asked for a rarer probability of 3 and
100 since 3 you would say yes it is not
very rare it's just 0.5 to have samples
generated by this distribution and then
100 which is far away as you can see
from these training sets that you would
get a very tiny rarer probability for
that so this
or metric to identify anomalous examples
so we will consider examples anomalies
when the rarer probability is glue and
acceptance threshold a given accept and
search the default acceptance threshold
is 10 to the minus 3 1 in thousand
examples so we use this mechanism to
design find anomalies a function which
you can give it a learn distribution of
the first argument and examples that you
want to find the anomalous ones in the
second one and it can give you the
anomalous examples and you can also
change the acceptance threshold and so
on but you can also directly use find
anomalies as here on the data but you
might think that how would like if you
don't have the learn distribution on
non-anomalous data so this is like a
chicken and egg problem you want to
distribution anonymous data to find
anomalies but on the other hand you
don't know where the anomalies are so we
have also a scheme for that we do a
cross-validation and we learn the
distribution and examples with a highest
rare probability and we train on that
and we find a normal is on the risk and
we do it few times if you don't have a
learn distribution in general you can go
to the commentation but there are a lot
of few properties that you can query
from fine anomalies like by default it
returns the anomalous examples find
anomalies for you and you can ask for
the position of the animal is rarer
probabilities of them and so on let's
look at one of the applications for
finding animals for images here I have a
C for 10 from the resource data federal
images as you know it's a standard pair
schmuck for a various type of images
like planes dogs cats and everything and
I added a few gist random noise to the
data set so I you can just learn the
distribution on those images and you can
ask for anomalous examples given that
oléron distribution I can see it doesn't
look it makes mistakes for sure but you
can and you can change the acceptance
threshold to see and explore different
outputs you can here I also added some
noise to few examples of the 3 for 10
and you can get noisy ones out as
anomalies so I change gear again and
another task unlocked we learn
distribution is synthesizing missing
values often you have data that are
missing offender or corruption in your
images and you would like to replace it
with better values so there are two
there are just only one main function
synthesized music value introducing 12
you can directly give it your examples
or you can again as a first argument
give their learned distribution and the
second or you take examples that you'd
like the missing value to be imputed so
very very similar to fine anomalies you
will learn a distribution and how it
works is you can easily conditioned the
distribution if you have like say you
have X access missing on this
two-dimensional vector that I just
learned distribution on you just
conditioned on the known values which is
you condition your distribution on the
4.5 and a y value and you draw a sample
for
X on that conditional distribution and
by default it would just give you a
missing and replace it with a new sample
and actually what you can have a
different in general the formalism works
like this that it we have a expected
maximization algorithm on their lives
which iterates between training the
distribution imputing the missing values
and just train the distribution again on
that impeded and just do it again and
again to get their best missing value
synthesized for you there are different
methods that you can use you can draw
just random samples from the conditioned
distributions by asking for the
evaluation and strategy to be random
sample or we can ask for the mode of the
distribution with mode finding sub
option and the learning method we just
ask for what type of method for learn
distribution to use so again let's look
at visualized data sets and learn
distribution on that so as you can see
we have the contours of the probability
density function and say I have the
point X is like around here but you
don't know what is y so if the y can't
be like anything on this axis so I just
synthesized missing values here and you
see that it gave me one point eight
which is around the mode of the peak of
one of the mode of the distribution
supply model a distribution here and
let's look at like around thousand
imputed missing values and as you can
see I'm drawing random sample from the
distribution
for the missing values on the condition
distribution which is conditions on
unknown X values and you see that it
goes around these small and sometimes it
goes around this mode you can look at
the histogram of these and you see is
following in kind of two model
distribution here and if you ask for a
mode it will just give you the one which
is closest to the mode of the of your
distribution so by default synthesized
missing value when you input your data
synthesized missing value treat missing
and in determined as missing and it will
replace them but you can change that
behavior there's the option missing
value pattern for example you can say
treat for as missing here and replace
and synthesized for that missing pattern
or we can just have other functions say
like less than three should be treated
as missing let's look at one application
here which is like in painter if you
have a like a corrupted image and you
want to impinge that image so I do it on
am nest data sets and had just a subset
of that to be fast again I learn a
distribution I just also specify what
method to use so the automation if you
don't do that your automation would find
best methods based on the cross on
trophy
and one thing is you can also ask for
information about the learned
distribution and you can see the
learning curve person training example
and lost the ant repeat and different
algorithms that it tries and so on back
to the synthesized music value given
that learn distribution I have like to
kind of cropped
the images and I say the treat 0.5 as
missing so and it would and use mode
finding candy like draw mode from the
conditioned distribution and it would it
will just fill in the missing values for
us so you can think of we were thinking
about adding other methods as gains a
torque gave by Jerome earlier today
would be good candidate for synthesizing
missing values for images and for right
now learn distribution and derivatives
functions like find anomalies and since
that signal does not work on sequences
like text audio and in the future we're
thinking about adding those and thank
you very much for your attention
that was all I have I would be happy to
take any questions
[Applause]